il ya des anciens qui m'a manqué au
football et jeudi ils sont autonomes et
je voulais donner ces gens-là mettre à
l'honneur pour les gens puissent la voir
parce qu'il ya des fois déjà parce qu'on
sait pas c'est qui et c'est pour ça que
je voulais mettre ces gens là l'honneur
le 1er novembre
on attend tout le monde ça commence à 7h
et c'est gratuit ça veut dire qu'il ya
deux ans honneur qui voit jouer au foot
il ya des cycles disent qu'ils vont
jouer au foot c'est pendant le match il
ya deux équipes qui vont jouer en somme
c'est de 8,8
c'est ce sont moitié et je demande à les
jeux devenus voir quels que soient jugés
en village et et il ya tout dedans
challenge il ya tous les champions
cyclistes qui sera là et je remercie
francis gustave qui va venir avec tous
les enfants il ya soixante enfants d'un
francis gustave qui soit à la tribune
que vont jouer et gratuit encore on a
c'est quand même un 5 1 on a fait du
voyage
on a fait une il ya trois ans n'avait
fait notre match de montpellier et l'an
dernier on a fait de matière de paris
s'est jamais pour nous en cinq ans on a
fait beaucoup de choses j'ai fait
dommage à camille alex éclisses en cadet
et je fais du vtt et de des jeunes de 6
à 16 ans je fais une balle sous gazeau
ont fait des déjeuners dansants
on a fait athlétisme pour les enfants
aussi de 6 à 14 ans on essaie de faire
des actions pour rassembler ces vidéos
on a fait associations on voit si
l'amicale de cette 7e mais on rassemble
des jets de la martinique